hannover namens luca und meine lieben
freunde es gibt ein paar dinge die ich
einfach nicht verstehen die ich
allerdings auch bisher noch nie erklärt
haben wollte wie ihr euch jetzt
allerdings wahrscheinlich fragt mensch
was das für ein dummer idiot ihr
vermutlich auch überhaupt nicht kapiert
was ich überhaupt meine würde ich
einfach mal sagen kann ich mit meinem
ersten punkt an und zwar schuhgrößen
warum hab ich ne 45 und warum ist das in
amerika eine 12 oder in england dann
wiederum eine ganz andere zahl warum hat
man sich nicht einfach darauf geeinigt
dass man einen zollstock nimmt seinen
fuß misst im zentimeter und das ist die
größe
international überall das gleiche das
wird für ihn 40 müssen ein fußball eine
blumenvase damit kommen wir allerdings
direkt schon zum nächsten thema und zwar
generell maßeinheit warum bin ich hier
in deutschland ein meter 93 aber in
amerika 6 4 6 4 ich bin 6,4 füße groß
oder auch temperatur einheiten hier ist
alles super geil geregelt bei null grad
gefriert wasser und bei 100 grad
verdampfte und in amerika
minus 60 grad fahrenheit wir zum
verfahren high und von diesem ganzen
meilen ding von er es gar nicht an
nächste sache die ich nicht checker
bluetooth
warum heißt das blaue zähne und wie kann
es sein dass ich hier ein handy herr
bund und hier und ist es ohne internet
das ihn
wie geht was von dir nach und generell
wiegende sms nach da oben und dann
wieder runter und dann ist wenn ich hier
auch endlich ist als eine sekunde da
was ist an mir vorbeigegangen nächstes
thema was ich heute morgen noch erlebt
habe ist stau
warum habt ihr nicht einfach ja ok just
eine spur gesperrt es geht von drei auf
zwei spuren aber damit ort mit euch
einfach normal ein wenn jeder noch mal
weiterfahren würde gäbe es keinen stau
die nächste sache die mich absolut an
die grenzen meines verstandes bringt ist
wie misst man die höhe eines berges
vorfand iran die können flugzeuge
fliegen
kommt mir jetzt bitte nicht an mit eurem
jana essen auf wind und das macht sinn
und dann kann er auch gleiten ja ich
weiß genau gleich mit schiffen ja es ist
irgendwie physikalisch logisch dass die
teile das können was sie können aber
warum können die so viel und ich nicht
nur wäre dies gerade beim thema
flugzeuge sind meine lieben freunde
warum habe ich auf 13.000 metern höhe
besseres wlan 1 in deutschland wenn ich
ein stockwerk unter fahre in parkhaus da
geht sogar mein verdammtes radio aus
ich zweifle nicht an
allem cds
oder früher sogar noch schallplatten wie
kann es sein dass da irgendwie so ein
zum teller ist und dann legt man
irgendwo drauf mit so einem ding und
dann kommt da musik raus
hell wie wird eine bohrinsel gebaut
nächste sache ist warum haben wir augen
braune
die haben keinen sinn mit dem mund kann
man essen mit der nase kann man riechen
mit den augen kann man gucken die
wimpern und nasenhaare sind dazu da um
irgendwie bakterien oder schadstoff oder
so abzuhalten haare machen auch keinen
sinn
vielleicht um warm zu halten wie
funktionieren spiegel wie werden spiegel
hergestellt aus was ist also wie kann es
sein dass das da was ist was vorher
nicht da sagt das dass ich das
nicht tun das nächste thema sind
lebensmittelallergien wie kann es sein
dass einige menschen irgendwie einen
fallschirmsprung überleben den wird ein
bein amputiert die verlieren irgendwie
weiß ich nicht was für sachen und die
können walter leben aber wenn irgendwer
muss ist stirbt er
woher weisst profen wo es wehtut
ich habe schmerzen im fuß und es ist weg
nach einer stunde
fünf tage später habe schmerzen in der
schulter ich nehme und darf es weg
die nächste sache auf die ich auch
überhaupt nicht auch klar komme ist wie
kann dieses wetter so gut ist
begeisterter minister von de
warum allerdings weg weiter und zwar
eine sache die ich selber schon häufig
an mir selber haben zu spüren bekommen
lassen generell da ganz andere sache
warum es deutsch so schwer
warum machen wir es nicht einfach wie im
englischen es gibt nur
darum gibt's bei uns der die dass dessen
darum dies dass allein aus heute ist
warum tut es uns männern unfassbar weh
wenn wir beispielsweise irgendwie einen
ball und gegen bekommen und warum sie
das dann auch hoch nimmt auch
ich bauchschmerzen davon bei 20 cm
darunter irgendwas passiert warum dürfen
kinder nicht scheiße sagen
[Musik]
sagt doch einfach scheiße das nächste
thema ist es eben nicht groß und zwar
hatte
diese ergibt das alles einen sinn
aber irgendwie auch nicht
wie kann es sein dass es für nahezu
alles was irgendwie gibt mittlerweile
tabletten gibt du hast da schmerzen im
inneren deines körpers und die haben
ganz genau etwas entwickelt was genau
dagegen hilft wie könnt ihr das checken
die wisst ihr dass die wm
also ich freu mich drüber aber ich kann
es mir nicht erklären sagte werdet ihr
denkt ich alle kennen und zwar sind es
diese chuck norris witze
wer war das
wieso sagt man dass er alles kann was
was hat er geleistet ich hab ich keine
ahnung wer das was macht ein ingenieur
weiß ich wie man das schreiben nächste
sache wenn ein land schulden hat die
beispielsweise deutschland oder
irgendein anderer staat oder keine
ahnung was warum drucken bin ich einfach
mehr geld
ich schon die kommentare dass alle
denken dass ich total dumm bin und ich
weiß auch dass ich auch alles davon eine
realistische und sinnvolle antwort im
internet finden werde aber ich will
diese sache noch nicht erklärt bekommt
wer hat die reihenfolge des alphabets
festgelegt
warum a b c d e f g warum nicht fbw dgb
ihre sache mit dem alphabet kann man
allerdings direkt hinzufügen warum dinge
generell so heißen wie sie heißen warum
ist dass die cash shop und das sogar die
sonne raum ist dass sie nicht mehr und
man sagt hey lass mal catwalk training
ich weiß wenn er sich an diese dinge
gewöhnt hat aber wer hat das irgendwann
mal festgelegt wer dachte sich so gelbe
lange fruchtbarer allgemein kann man
sich da fragen wie sprache entstanden
ist
eine sache die ich ebenfalls nicht
verstehe sind drucker
wie kann es sein dass ich über das
internet irgendwas an den drucker sende
und er verarbeitet das so dass er das
dann mit den patronen printed auf dem 4
es gibt so viele dinge die ganz viele
sachen können dann gibt es nicht jetzt
kommt die sonne raus
ist auch so ein ding wir sind so
geisteskrank weit entfernt von der sonne
aber trotzdem wenn ich mich dann ein
bisschen so lange drinnen aufhalten ist
meine haut direkt vor ort droht
das ist aber schon sehr hell hier egal
was ich freue mich wieder schön dann hab
ich auch das heutige werden bevor das
sie noch komplett halbiert wenn es euch
gefallen hat das kind einen daumen wo
und wie die hütte ab und beim kanal und
klickt auf die glocke hinschaut zudem
gern wie in der video beschreibung und
vorbei dann findet nämlich ein treffer
wollte ich mich ist ein bisschen
orientiert habe ich weiß dass alle dinge
die ich eigentlich gerade gesagt habe
eine logische erklärung beinhalten und
wenn ihr mir und anderen die sich das
vielleicht auch gefragt haben
weiterhelfen können dann schreibt bitte
nicht unten in die kommentare weil wir
könnten selber prügeln aber
irgendwie muss das leben ja auch ein
bisschen fragwürdig seien was und andere
dinge die ihr nicht checkt wo ich
vielleicht den zweiten teil machen
könnte schreibt uns in die kommentare
ich gebe jetzt vergraben